[Music]
or at such a classic people love to come
I'm imagining it's hard to believe it's
so much wild insane stuff happen in that
movie but I'm told there is some stuff
that ended up on the cutting room floor
that no one ever got to see yes yes
there's anything that anything we should
hear about this one scene I always liked
and I had this dilemma whether to put it
in the final cut in the end it didn't
make it but there was a scene where
Borat was trying to get work he was out
of money and it's after I'd had the
naked fight the guy it's out of my face
that's another story
yeah an unpleasant one and so Borat gets
a job as a porno star right and so there
was so we had a real porno movie being
shot in a hotel room and the idea was a
couple of having sex and I was playing
room service yeah you know I'd come in
at starving sex so the guy shouts action
this is real yes this is real it's a
real porno movie it's the real porno
movie
real gentle real director yes exactly
so I knock on the door you know they're
having sex I come in and they're having
sex and I go yeah no problem I return
[Laughter]
anyway the director shouts comp and he
goes no no no you come in you see the
girl the guy and the guy you cut you
know take cat you take sea cow and you
stop doing it right you know not very
pleasant guy yeah I go okay I understand
and I come back in I know it goes all
right action I come back him again
knocking until coming I go oh you're
still go out at down again they said no
cut cut cut and explained to me now
you've got it
you have to have sex with this woman
right hey not this one and so finally
Paul Ryan's Borat kitty I go okay I have
a sexy time everybody please he'll live
they're all know the cameras have to
stay in the room and I got a sexy vibe
I says because we're making a movie and
I go all right sir venture get that I
said okay the problem is she have no
hair on her pubis I cannot be it cannot
go out but cannot become tARGIT and he
goes yeah oh yeah obviously she doesn't
have any hair in her pubes I got sure
you have a nuclear today anyway I say
listen I go I cannot the man kids once
you have no hair he said he gets so
frustrated they says all right you know
what we're gonna put some hair on on
that area I'm saying it's insane so this
is over an hour you go we're gonna put
some hair in that area because we're
we're gonna get some hair goes you know
what I've had enough I'm gonna cut my
own hair so cut to me on the phone at
hello room service
yeah we'll like some scissors to remove
their hair from this director so we can
put it on this lady's pubis
anyway they bring up Caesar now they
bring up scissors he chops his hair and
he glues it to her crotch and I say okay
great now I will take my prophylactic
and I bring out this huge leather condom
I go my father yells they're down here
[Applause]
and they say you guys no no you know no
prophylactics no condoms and I go okay
great but no problem we all have a sexy
time I love a sexy time I have had the
simplest over 24 times and she said
syphilis I'm not doing it that's how you
got out of that's how I got out of it I
love it
you